aquí su madre Helen a kiki comparten un
vínculo fuerte Más allá de la relación
madre e hija ambas fueron diagnosticadas
con cáncer de mama hace poco más de un
año en beirut
nos dimos mucho apoyo mutuo no me
imaginaba la fuerza que tiene mi hija de
verdad yo le di fuerza y ella me dio
fuerza nos apoyamos mutuamente pero me
dio mucha pena verla estar enferma no es
para ella es Demasiado joven para eso
juntas afrontaron las sesiones de
quimioterapia la caída del cabello y
también la ansiedad por no saber si
sobrevivirán ya que en Líbano sumido en
una profunda crisis económica conseguir
medicamentos no es nada fácil
el miedo en Líbano no es solo que la
medicina esté cortada son muchos temas
que complican conseguirla tenemos que ir
y volver cien veces para buscarla pero
no hay combustible y muchas veces toca
esperar todo se suma a nuestra
enfermedad y la preocupación que tenemos
tras someterse quimioterapia y una
mastectomía zaidi debe seguir un
tratamiento durante 10 años con una
píldora diaria y una inyección de
hormonas mensual que no ha logrado
conseguir en beirut motivo por el que
como muchas enfermas de cáncer en Líbano
decidió recurrir a redes sociales y
consiguió que un viajero de Jordania le
llevara en medicamento me sentí muy
emocionada porque lograron ayudarme
tanto en tan al mismo tiempo un logro
que también dio tranquilidad a Helen
Aunque solo en parte
me digo que lo importante es ella Espero
que el país pueda encontrar una solución
a esto y que podamos encontrar la
medicación no sé vivimos con miedo
las autoridades médicas han advertido
que la situación ha empeorado en los
últimos tres meses y como zaidi y Helen
son muchas las mujeres que enfrentan el
miedo a no poder recibir tratamiento en
Líbano